if you're a visual learner today's Cloud
tip is for you when I first started
learning about Google Cloud it was
difficult to decide where to start the
cloud is huge and I was having trouble
visualizing how each piece fit together
and what area I wanted to specialize in
thankfully there's a book for that
visualizing Google cloud has 101
Illustrated references for cloud
engineers and Architects as a visual
learner I'm a huge fan of learning this
way with colorful sketch notes and it's
a fun way to learn something new by
sitting down with a nice book so the
cloud is feeling overwhelming give
learning via sketch notes a try check
out our description for links to the
book in helpful videos featuring sketch
notes from Google Cloud